that's a high-paying skillset yeah it's
the most important thing that you could
start off doing it's more difficult to
succeed in the markets than it is to
succeed in the Olympics okay
people but people don't realize that
diversification that is the thing that I
would say particularly for anybody it is
the most important thing it's if you
know how to do that well wanna be happy
build a life not just the business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believed life and how you can invest
like billionaire Ray Dalio also if you
want to have more self love and
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below if everything has to
work in two to three years then that
limits what you can do you have to
explain why you're the right person to
lead and above all you have to know your
numbers you really have to believe the
Internet's going to be mainstream a lot
of people are gonna get out there and
use it okay let's tick it off with the
most important rule diversify I'm big on
diverse viewer very big location of
knowing how knowing how to adverse by
well is more important than almost
anything people don't understand this
but that an evergreen principle yes
that's it evergreen principle and the
reason I'm saying that the way it is
it's almost like a casino making its
money okay okay
the way that you do it is you get an
edge so now when you have to make a bet
I've got a bet against the whole world
the world has view on something is
reflected in the price so when I think
something is attractive or unattractive
that means I have to bet against the
whole world and whether that's right or
not that's difficult I get it right you
know more often that I get it wrong but
I'm going to get it wrong sometimes and
so when you can take a lot of different
bets what you can do is like the casino
you'll get your average that your bet
will
but you'll reduce your risk event one of
those tables not being the table that's
paying off and so that margin that so I
can reduce my risk without reducing my
return by knowing how to diversify and
I'd say that's particularly true
important for the people or listening
near investors because what they've got
to do some risk without reduce in return
that's right that's the specialty that's
right
elaborate a little bit more if you don't
mind on that so we do some risk without
reducing the return because a lot of
times if I'm reducing the risk it means
my returns also going lower but you're
saying no no we're not even reducing the
return right I mean that's a high-paying
skill set yeah it's the most important
thing that you could start off doing if
you have a number of equally good likely
bets but they're uncorrelated like the
casino you know one table is going to
get me a margin like this but take
another table and it makes me a margin
like this but I might have volatility
about those let me take all those
investments that I think will make ten
percent so that's my return but they're
uncorrelated with each other that means
I'll still get to ten I don't lower my
dad but my diversification means I lower
my risk so I improved my return to risk
ratio ah is that an art that you can
teach oh yeah yeah I wrote about it in
there's a what I call a section in this
book the holy grail of investing it's a
three pages long and it explains
basically this important thing because
when that epiphany happened to me and
how I would do it it changed everything
by being able to do that because how old
I can improve through diversification I
can improve my return to risk ratio by a
factor of five so by diversifying okay
the return relative to the risk I can
keep my returns the same and reduce my
risk to one-fifth if I know how to do
verse 5 well and that's why I'm
explaining it's not all that complicated
it's simply explained in the book but in
any case that is the holy grail of
investing ok that's a big thing if you
start to know that that's what you're
going for it changes everything and it's
so important for the average person is
listening and don't let me explain why
that is because the average person who's
listening too many people think that
they can go into this very difficult
zero-sum game of betting against the
consensus and be right you know what I
mean
in other words investor says I'm gonna
go in the markets I'm gonna make money
betting against the consensus and be
right right because the consensus is
built into the price ok ok that's what's
up so it's think of it it's like going
to a horse race and there's handicaps ok
you're not going to pick the best horse
and you're not going to pick the best
company a terrible company can be a
better investment than a terrific
company a terrible company could be a
better investment just like the terrible
horse can be a better because the odds
that are changing like you go into that
and that becomes the longshot but
because the longshot is going to pay off
25 to 1 right if he comes in that you
could just as likely bet on the longshot
as the leader and it's going to be
equally likely that you're going to make
money right otherwise you otherwise the
market would be doing the opposite well
the market is like that right in other
words if everybody believes that
something's going to be terrific
ok then everybody's betting on it and
its price is high so it's not what's
best necessarily it's what's best
relative to what's in the price what's
discounted in order for you to win in
the game like you're gonna go in and
pick what's a good investment you are
playing against others you have to
realize that because that's it's all in
the odds it's like when you go to the
track you're going to have to play
against the handi
cappers okay so it is very difficult for
you to beat me or to beat others who
were put in 1500 people and hundreds of
millions of dollars into how to win in
that game right and there's a lot of
people and I find it challenging I find
it difficult so it's difficult to win in
that game it's it's difficult to win in
that game individually by placing the
bets it's difficult to win in that game
it's more difficult to succeed in the
markets than it is to succeed in the
Olympics okay people but people don't
realize that they think I'm going to go
have a nap you're okay but there are
more people trying to do it in the
markets that are try to do it in the
Olympics and so nobody would say I'm
gonna run and compete in the Olympics
when you realize how difficult that is
okay but you can diversify well anybody
could diversify well so if we look at
the what the world will be like in five
years or three years or one year okay
like we're coming in the presidential
election we have all these things going
on okay you want to bet on it okay wise
guy give it a shot that's is that is
that easy that's what you're okay well
the only way I can do it is I need to
diversify my bets well I wouldn't want
to concentrate on any one of those your
and I tried it I'll take like the casino
I will take I'll take that bet and I'll
take this bet and I'll take a bunch of
those bets but for you was the average
investor you're probably not going to
even be able to pick which horses got
the the edge wasn't relative to the
handicappers okay and so diversification
that is the thing that I would say
particularly for anybody it is the most
important thing it's if you know how to
do that well so that's why I'm saying
you know that page those couple of pages
here was something I wanted to pass
along to you you'll see a lot of people
will say that's a boring formula or it's
an outdated you know you'll be in the
industry so this whole beverage
suffocation is a boring formula etcetera
etc and I'm just going to say I went
from nothing you asked me okay I my
dad's a jazz musician middle class or
lower middle class family I had nothing
other than parents who cared maybe you
know
and I go to a good public school and
that was the only thing I had and if I
took that and I say okay Here I am with
the things that has happened over the
markets and making money and here at
building a business and so on there was
there a limited number of principles
that I want to pass along to people
because I think if they can get those
principles that that would be extremely
valuable and this is not boring so when
I come back and you say okay that arkad
lajjo is not boring that was a very
successful an exciting arc in life and
this is one of those principles so if
you take diversifying well how to
diversify well please go understand that
principle it's only a couple of pages
please go understand that principle
because when you have savings and you
think how much money do I need for my
kids education or my retirement or
whatever it is and so on and if you
don't know how to do this well you're
risking a lot and if you do it well and
so on it produces an enormous amount of
opportunity now I have a special bonus
clip from Kevin O'Leary on how to invest
in growing markets that I think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
take an action here we go question
number one where do you need to
diversify number two what's the growing
market you can invest in and number
three how will you improve your
investment knowledge this week and if
you made it this far in the video I want
to celebrate you give me a hashtag
believe down the comments what areas of
the world do you like right now where
you're investing you know I look at it
very simplistically I say where's the
GDP growth because that's the rising
tide for any operation a telco a toll
road a consumer goods company you'd
rather own that in a country that has
GDP growth north to 3% so right now you
know I used to be 70% invested in Canada
I'm down to less than 25% here because
we're not growing we're not growing in
the US I like Brazil India China Asia
Cambodia Thailand they got it cooking
over there they're growing so I'd rather
own the Brazilian telco than any
Canadian telco I mean you look at the
the worst returns in telco or in Canada
you can buy a Brazilian telco there's
been a phenomenal investment in the last
five years and the
great thing about these companies
overseas is they're so big now so huge
they're issuing the Securities and US
dollars and I can hedge that back to the
Canadian dollar for next to nothing
what's the difference between
billionaires and the rest of the world
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I have
paid attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always